[Music]
this is capitalism versus socialism i've
heard your argument morally speaking
they make their money off of exploiting
those at the bottom of the economy to me
that's
nonsensically outrageous and immoral
when we're if we're comparing to
economic systems one that says all right
we have to place priority we have to we
have to determine what we value as a
society
education health care or one that says
what to determine what we value as a
society the ability for the wealthiest
people in the world to get wealthier at
the expense of others
uh it sounds like that's what you're
advocating privatize schools i'd like to
know i'd like to know how the wealthiest
people in the world get wealthy at the
expense of poor people who have no money
in the first place particularly when you
see that statistically literally half
the world's population has been raised
out of poverty since 1980 specifically
because of free markets capitalism and
private property rights yeah well this
is the problem with the right the alt
right in the right wing today it's this
sort of it's this autistic view of the
world and that you know if you have an
iphone fine you don't have to worry
about it anymore right technology's got
like i'm saying these that's not what
really matters i'm talking i'm talking
about people you know get out in the
street right talk with these people see
how people are living in the united
states i don't think you understand the
point it's not about how much money the
poor have i'm not saying that the rich
are mugging them in an alleyway they're
not getting rich off of the poor's money
they're getting rich off of exploiting
their labor
right this is because the rich own the
means that since the industrial
revolution they own the means of
productions we don't want that to go to
the government but we want it to be in
the hands of a few people who get
billion-dollar bonuses while the while
the poor can't even get a living wage at
fifteen dollars an hour we would say
people lobbying the government to make
sure they make seven dollars more people
on planet earth the poorest people on
planet earth live in one of two systems
either a system that does not guarantee
private property ownership because there
is no actual governmental system to
guarantee private property ownership or
two a system where private property
ownership does not exist and the
government owns the means of production
and does not operate in even state
capitalistic fashion but operates for
the quote unquote good of the workers
when that happens poor people emerge
this is what's happened in venezuela
that's what happened in the ussrs what
happens in cuba it's what happened in
north korea or alternatively it's what
happened in places like somalia or sudan
so again the idea that rich people are
somehow exploiting
labor unless you can show how they're
doing so by pointing a gun at somebody
or using another government gun to point
at somebody
free alienation of labor is a is a
fundamental human right your decision to
work for a given wage is your decision
and no one's forcing you into it
again it comes back to this it's this
simplistic reductive you know on the
spectrum view of how the world works
we're not just talking about how much
money people have in their pocket we're
talking about a system right now that
doesn't frankly allow poor people to
become the next poke brother or the
walton family you know the walmart is
probably one of the biggest
one of the biggest recipients of welfare
in the country because they don't even
pay their people a living wage see i
mean we're talking about capitalism it's
totally cool to bail out banks it's
totally cool to make sure that uh oil
companies get subsidies but once we
cross the line into education
now that's where we draw the line you're
on your own it's not capitalism that's
that's that yeah that's not capitalism
subsidies to walmart is not capitalism
that's state-sponsored that's
state-sponsored mercantilism essentially
it's it's
really closer to economic fascism
and the i i agree that walmart would be
actually forced by the labor market to
pay its workers more if you did not have
the government picking up the the food
stamps on the other end that is a
supplementation of of wages by the
federal government toward businesses
like walmart i don't believe that big
businesses should be receiving subsidies
from the federal government any more
than i believe that individuals
generally should be receiving subsidies
from government
so oh okay so if walmart if welfare just
didn't exist if ebt cars just didn't
exist walmart would pay 15 an hour is
that a fact mr meta economist
well they would in fact have to raise
their wages because people cannot work
for a non-living wage or they would be
dead by definition do you think walmart
cares if you die in a gutter
do you think walmart goes out they don't
care if they can't get you to work i
mean if they've got no one to stock the
shelves because you're dead in a gutter
i do think walmart cares yeah i don't
think i don't think they care i think
they automate and this is a problem we
see now with it with new technology
listen there aren't the same kind of
jobs for people not everyone's going to
be a harvard lawyer not everyone's going
to be a harvard lawyer's wife slash
doctor right some people actually have
to go out there and work on the assembly
line and make the nice things that you
enjoy but that becomes automated and
these people get left behind right
that's the problem we have seven million
unfilled jobs in the united states right
now seven million unfilled jobs in the
united states right now and essentially
record low unemployment so
i'm failing to see the millions of
people who are desperately
missing a job
other than folks who probably should
move out of communities where factories
died 25 years ago
oh yeah so that's their solution just i
move
it's not my problem
really well no it's it's the fact is
that america was built by people who
were moving even if we're talking about
natural gas
if we're talking about uh coal any of
these it still is a finite resource
right capitalism does not have any
there's no moral imperative to move to
something that's renewable if something
that is a more toxic alternative let's
not say
horrible for the environment let's just
let's go with what you say right and say
okay fracking's better than than
than the typical kind of extraction
methods for all right listen let's get
let's give you that it's still a finite
resource there's no profit motive to
move to something more helpful for the
environment
until it runs out
well i mean there has been a profit
motive to to move to more helpful
technologies for the environment
considering the significantly higher gas
mileage that we get now than we used to
in the 1970s so what was the what was
the profit motive there presumably
government subsidies efficient vehicles
that use less fill that use less fuel
now as government subsidies the same
thing that people the conservatives the
alt-right they complain about tesla
government subsidies the government
stepped in and offered incentives for
more fuel-efficient cars
uh that's why it was not it was not mere
subsidies alone it was it was also the
fact that there was high demand as oil
prices rose for smaller vehicles when
oil prices go down there's less demand
for for smaller vehicles when oil prices
go up there's more demand for smaller
vehicles also the left has been
complaining about the idea of peak oil
for some decades now and we've not yet
reached peak oil plus with regard to
technological development would i love
to see whoever cracks the code on
renewable cheap energy is going to make
more money than anyone in the history of
humankind the big problem here is that
solar is simply not capable of
generating the amount of energy
necessary to power entire civilizations
and carbon-based fuel is the most
efficient source of energy hold on a
second hold on a second ring ring angela
merkel oh
it's for you she says that's [ __ ]
okay so all right
germany bro they've got they've been
using solar and wind for years they they
moved their entire energy dependence to
renewable resources
well germany is taking an enormous
amount of actual gasoline and natural
gas from iran so that's that's not
completely true
they've
converted all of their energy all their
national energy to solar or wind germany
i mean it's not a good i mean i took
government intervention right i know
it's not the military i know it's not i
know it's not the police force right
we're on board with that but to be
honest with you i'll be honest with you
mr turden i don't know that much about
the the german energy situation so i'll
have to check that out and get back to
you no shocker no shocker benjamin
shapiro avoids learning about germany in
their current affairs
well some of this so obviously right is
sort of self-serving recently you had
did a video i want to make sure on
pinterest and i got removed i know you
got really upset about that can you
explain that to people who don't know
you did a video on pinterest um you know
sort of
making some accusations and uh i think
you docked somebody and it was removed
and you were you're mad yeah and this is
probably the perfect example of why any
kind of restrictions on speech
particularly when they say hate speech
is so insidious
i did a video commenting on publicly
available information
but because the story was damaging to
this massive billion dollar corporation
apparently it's my understanding right
so this is where we're at so far in the
store i haven't reported this yet but it
seems like a legal firm filed a you know
privacy complaint and youtube just takes
the content down even though it's public
so this is you know a massive legal firm
with probably hundreds of millions of
dollars maybe tens of millions i don't
know
getting journalism taken down
by a uh by lying essentially or putting
pressure on youtube and to be clear for
people who don't know this information
was made public by james o'keefe so you
know they can check the sources for
themselves
right so so so james o'keefe does an
expose any and yeah let's call it that
yeah
well yeah yeah you have to like the guy
but he had a whistle blow around the
record and if and if you wanna if you
don't wanna trust james you can trust
the guy who did get fired from from
pinterest saying this happened okay now
if you wanna if you wanna argue that
journalism violates someone's privacy i
think you're wrong but james o'keefe did
publish someone's name i still think
james o'keefe is in the right on that
issue but then it gets even crazier when
i'm simply commenting on what everyone
already knows and they still say you
cannot do that now you have massive
unaccountable companies like no one
elected pinterest to determine who what
beliefs you're allowed to have but they
are suppressing information and once
people found out because regulation is
coming pinterest then acts in the
interest or i should say youtube and
these other platforms because even
twitter took down james o'keefe's videos
they're protecting each other as far as
i'm concerned because they know
regulations that's their bottom dollar
that's the key there is as far as i want
to make sure people understand as far as
tim poole is concerned uh let me ask you
this now you say that you're more
moderate left but you just mentioned you
know james o'keefe and pinterest and
obviously you've defended stephen
crowder with the carlos mozart conflict
um do you ever worry you're on the wrong
side of history because you just you're
consistently siding with and defending
bullies does that ever occur to you but
i've i've made several videos in the
past several weeks defending the left i
made a video yesterday defending an
auntie you know an anti-fascist who had
who was suspended from twitter because
his book had uh you know kkk heads on it
you know so it's it's i'll tell you what
happens you know people like you skylar
only ever watch the videos that are
supporting the speech of people you
don't like and you ignore it when i make
videos defending the speech of people on
your side it's not sensational enough
for you well
i'm not
i'm not super familiar with your videos
it doesn't show up in my suggested feed
that's probably true too yeah so i i
don't listen i'm not as i haven't seen
all of your videos but if you say that
you know i'll take your word for it um
and i'll tell you what's really funny is
this this author who got suspended from
twitter which he shouldn't have because
of his book cover starts ragging on me
when he's complaining about it i
defended the guy you know so i'll tell
you what man i'm gonna defend speech i
defended flag burning right my
principles are where they lie it doesn't
matter i i don't you know in fact i find
myself more likely to agree with the
speech of people who are moderate left i
think there's a lot of people way too
far to the left then i would a
conservative but the issue is is it's
it's it's it's obvious well then what
first they come for you then they come
for me well then why would you defend
someone like like a stefan crowder right
with a smaller guy like carlos mozar and
and you know less than a hundred
thousand followers that's a clear
example of crowder obviously had
violated terms of service by making
hateful content uh which youtube said
and a big channel with almost 4 million
subscribers going after
a lifelong um lgbtq advocate that is not
a prime example of
well first
youtube said
stephen didn't break any rules well they
didn't did he monetize them so you know
they did right and because he caused in
their in their view they said it was
harmful to the community but here's the
bigger problem would you prefer it if
carlos mazza was banned from twitter and
youtube is that is that what you're
advocating for
because uh carlos mazza has repeatedly
done the exact same thing in fact one of
the big problems is first of all i
understand comedy right i'm a big fan of
george carlin and george carlin has a
has he had this bit in the early 90s
where he used every racial slur in the
book and said it's not the words it's
the person behind the words you've got
to be worried about and and the reason
why that's so important is that carlos
mazza used those words on himself
if we held everyone to the same standard
carlos mazza would have been banned from
youtube way before stephen crowder ever
got to the point of criticizing him well
no no no that's a listen that's a false
equivalency if we're going to use george
carlin's example it would be yeah it's
the person behind them
it's just like it's not the same for a
black person to reappropriate the n-word
versus a white person calling them that
carlos mazza can use those words someone
like uh uh stefan crowder
they he was using it clearly in a
derogatory way it's the person who is
not an ally
so you agree with george carlin's
position on it that it's it's the person
behind it and the intent the context
that matters context is what's important
right yes context and of course the
context is problematic when you see that
uh you know someone like stefan crowder
clearly violated guidelines and it was
uh harassing content
well if you agree the context is
relevant then we're talking about a
comedian who's describing a person the
way they describe themselves
you know and and what's really important
here is because this is a common tactic
we see from you know activists like
carlos mazza interestingly who
repeatedly has called for various people
to be taken down you know the carlos
mazza
this is a screenshot so i haven't
confirmed this but apparently he
referred to gay men as ghouls like in an
absolutely derogatory way so if we're
gonna if we're gonna take him at his
word and that's how he describes people
then i don't trust him when he describes
himself that it's supposed to be you
know ingest or reappropriating the
language it shouldn't matter if you know
what to back to the point i kind of
derailed these activists you know what
they've done with crowder is they've
gone through two years worth of content
and snipped together all of these out of
context times he said certain things but
youtube realized when you watch the full
segment it was a passing moment and it
wasn't targeting carlos specifically
based on those traits it was just him
talking about something and then
mentioning the identity of of mazza by
all means
you can be mad at crowder for doing that
i i'm willing to listen to your opinion
but we go back and look at what carlos
mazza is saying throw milkshakes at
people and he actually and again i want
to clarify i didn't confirm this tweet
yet but it's going around now because
mazza has repeatedly referred to
minority seems like there's a lot of
that in your content if i may say a lot
of unconfirmed screenshots and tweets
but you know listen you no that's
actually not true at all no i i i
maybe less than i would say agree to
disagree uh but only if i there was even
a slight chance that i was incorrect
which we know is not the case here you
are yeah because i use i actually use
newsguard which is a um third-party
rating agency i actually have great
disagreements with but i use it on
purpose as a check on my own personal
bias so yes everything i use is
confirmed i'm not as familiar with
newsguard i tend to reference vice and
vox quite a bit let me ask you
i was the founding member of vice news
so you'll probably uh trust me in that
regard right now well good for you uh
where are you you're not working for
them anymore i guess right now we can
revisit let's circle back to that maybe
we can do it a shallow dive because that
seems about where we're we're going here
if i were to walk into your house right
now and just and harass you and and call
you all sorts of names and get right up
in your face and not leave after you've
asked me to leave and continue uh
harassing you uh without any without any
any uh refuge for you
would you think that that is a crime for
me to do that
i don't know why you're asking the
questions
so now again this is where we talk about
the constitution in guns now we have
fully automatic ar-15s and things change
right times change we need to adapt and
we both agreed on that to some extent
now online people like alex jones they
have the ability to invade your house
digitally continually and harass and
berate you can always shut off not
necessarily that's a thing you can't you
can't shut off everything you can't
block people you can't mute people on
every platform then they can have your
email on youtube you you know it shows
up in your suggested feed the point is
especially that's a silly argument you
can just shut the whole thing off if you
want so it's a silly argument it's not
like someone invading your house
so because you can shut it off at any
time okay so no that's just not that's
just not going anywhere that argument
well what if someone has a computer in
their house then if they have a computer
in a house then it means that someone
can invade their their house that way
digitally there's there's no way to find
a space away from particularly people
like alex jones most egregious offenders
right who spread conspiracies and
effectively like lead to doxing of
people um i mean that's just a lot of
this the thing is too it's again
again
the the question is more fundamental
let's assume that it's a bad idea for
poorly supported conspiracy theories to
be formulated and distributed yeah let's
assume that
yeah fine well we don't need to put it
in air quotes we could probably both
assume it the question is what should
you do with people who are doing that
and the one answer is well do what you
can to silence them and drive them
underground the other is let them talk
and let people make up their own minds
and my sense is
and is that people are wise enough to
listen to people of that sort and decide
that that's too extreme
now not everyone because
conspiracy theorists can find followers
among people who are disagreeable and
somewhat paranoid but it's best for
everyone including the conspiracy
theorists themselves that those things
are aired in public discussion because
it helps keep people sane you know like
i've known people who are a little bit
obvious i disagree yeah but that's
because you don't know what you're
talking about does ever concern you that
you might be on the wrong side of
history
what mostly concerns me is whether i
make a mistake when i'm talking and so i
i'm i'm not thinking about the wrong
side of history precisely
so
does it concern me that i might be
making mistakes that concerns me all the
time
but um i thought most i thought the
things that i say through very carefully
and
you know i'm perfectly willing to live
or die by them let's say so um
well i'll ask you that because you know
we've gone through a litany of of of you
know using people's preferred pronouns
of the idea of compassion um neither of
which do you support and then we've gone
through things like alex jones and
extremists and social media and these
are ideas that do you i wonder if you're
constantly finding yourself defending
just bad like bad people and even if
you're not one if you mostly what i find
myself doing is
being supported by a very large number
of people and being
what would you call put on the spot in
various uncomfortable ways by a tiny
noisy minority of radical collectivists
so that's mostly what i feel or mostly
what i experience
so
outside of history isn't that your buddy
sure who says don't care about your
feelings so if you that's how you feel
i'm sorry that's not my intent here
uh but again that is
selfauthoring.com12 rules for life
i hate to say it but you guys the the
progressives uh you've you've become a
secular religion and if anyone doesn't
agree with you all the time they must be
destroyed uh i don't i don't consider
myself a secularist or a member of any
religion at all
you're not a secularist or a member of a
religion
i uh i do i want to make sure that so
you believe that conservatives are more
decent because they want to live in a
world where they can yell the n-word or
yell the f word uh by the way i want to
clear not that you want to yell like cf
you know like a pejorative toward people
from your uh marginalized group you
believe they're more decent because they
believe in defending that right i want
to make sure i just not misrepresenting
you here no well first i should be clear
i am in no way marginalized uh i am a
human being with equal rights equal
rights that that you have and that
i would imagine uh virtually uh and
everyone you know has um but i yes i do
want to live in a society where you're
allowed to say whatever you want you
know a fence is on the side of the
people who take it so if you were
walking down the street let's say and
someone said oh god look at that guy
with his uh what what do you call a
beanie again
a toque and that ridiculous mustache and
his and his you know you're over
pronunciating the you
dick
you know and his lesbian lesbian-like
shirt and all of that and someone said
some mean things to you well it's on you
to decide whether you're gonna take
offense to that but but the option let's
say you said okay i'm not okay with
someone being all right saying whatever
they want to say the option is we're
going to start jailing people for speech
now of course this is actually bizarrely
where the the left wants to go with this
which is why they label everyone nazis
because why would you let a nazi speak
so we're in a we're in a slippery slope
here and uh yeah well i appreciate that
mr uh exchange of ideas went straight to
ad hominem this is not a lesbian shirt
uh i purchased it at orvis there
happened to be lesbians who shop there
uh but i consider myself an ally and
it's a beautiful experience and
sometimes we shop together so i don't
necessarily know that's relevant to my
ideas um but i would like to ask you
this as you mentioned society sort of
collectively if we can agree to the same
values and then i'll express my view but
what this is collectivism that you're
advocating
what would you like to see how would you
like to see society go forward since i
know you've railed against the platform
and canceled culture how would you like
to see the current state of our
discourse improved
what would you change about quote
unquote control culture and um how would
that look
yeah well just to be clear skylar i am
not advocating for collectivism i'm
advocating for what the founders wanted
which is that we have certain we have
god-given rights that the government is
there to protect the government doesn't
give us rights it can protect those
god-given rights and then those rights
are laid out in the constitution and in
the bill of rights what i'd like to see
going forward is uh more people more
good decent
uh progressives like yourself uh willing
to talk about these issues uh clearly
the vape is helping you sort of
you know take a more open approach to
this and i think what's happened
unfortunately is that most progressive
these days they believe that they
in and of themselves that their own mind
is knows exactly what's right and that
everything that came before them was
bigoted and racist and awful and they're
gonna have to hate their grandparents
and they're gonna have to hate barack
obama one day because he ran against gay
marriage the first time and a whole
bunch of other things so i hope that the
progressives will take a moment and pull
us back from the ledge because i believe
that most people that live here in these
united states of america are pretty
decent and by the way
my dog emma who's been here this whole
time she's been very quiet she she uh
she agrees with me too it's not it's not
such a terrible place here the good old
usfa
well um i appreciate that i appreciate
you bringing him into the conversation
uh i did realize after uh our last
couple of uh conversations here on
devil's advocate that we do need more
equal representation
of our our sisters of course in the good
fight right now i would say this emma
identifies as a cat by the way
i can't in good conscience tell a woman
that it's in her best interest to have
an abortion not when all the data out
there says
that by her having an abortion she will
not do well emotionally she will suffer
great trauma
and
that she will essentially be having to
heal from yet another traumatic incident
in her life
so i mean if i'm a person who says i'm
really going to support women
i don't want to support them being
re-traumatized by abortion after
something's as heinous as rape
well i can both agree it's heinous so if
you're saying that the the outcomes are
better for women who are raped to carry
the child sounds to me like well why
stop rape
i mean they're doing better they're
doing better by your logic right they're
doing better if they're raped to have a
baby so what's what's the difference
well i don't think they're doing better
than women who haven't been raped
oh you're just saying they're doing
better than women who've been raped and
have abortions performed
yes um yeah uh i i don't know i'd be
curious to see that data here's
something that's important to me what's
the difference for example let's do a
thought exercise this
baby all right this fetus this zygote is
entirely dependent on the mother right
there's no possible chance at viability
uh
so
what's the difference between let's say
a mother not uh properly caring for the
baby not properly let's say maybe she's
malnourished or she uh doesn't take
prenatal vitamins right
is that considered at that point would
that be considered murder in your eyes
because the idea here is listen this
baby is completely dependent on the
mother it's not a viable human being
outside of the womb so again it comes to
this idea of
forcing women to take care of
effectively what is a parasite
i think we have to look at it a
different way i think we want women to
take care of themselves
so
if a woman is malnourished
then we need to look at what's happening
in her life
because that's not only affecting the
life of her baby but that's affecting
her life
so i'm not really sure
even in the end what that has to do with
abortion because if a woman is
not eating if she's starving to death
then
we want to make sure that we are taking
care of her and that will in turn take
care of her child
right but the point here is we're kind
of getting to the argument of viability
the baby is not viable without the
mother
so um where do we where is the
government yeah i have a i have a 12
week old and i can tell you
he can't live without me either
well he can breathe on his own right he
has of course he needs to be cared for
but that's different from there's a
difference between that and actual
viability the ability to survive merely
outside of the womb
basic primary functions you know central
nervous system the ability to breathe
developed lungs uh that's not the case
with these zygotes to which you're
referring does that not enter into the
equation at all viability to define a
human being or
at least as it relates to rights i mean
the mother who is viable
should her rights not matter at that
point even though she's a viable human
being on her own she has to take care of
an unviable human being because ivy
johnson says so
well i mean viability is not really that
important to me i mean it either
is
a innocent human life or it's not and
uh whether it's viable or not i mean
that's sort of a moot point we have a
responsibility to
take care of
humans
that are in our care
i have a responsibility to take care of
my eight children
i have a responsibility to
care for my children when they are in
the womb
and viability
really is such a it's so subjective
because
as medical science continues to advance
viability
the weeks that determine viability
continue
to decrease so
you know
even 30 years ago a baby that was born
at 30 weeks gestation would have a very
very difficult time
surviving
um at 30 weeks now we've got babies
being born alive at 21 22 weeks that are
surviving outside of the womb so we
can't really dictate what's moral or
immoral
based on
medical science that continues to
advance well i do think it has somewhat
of an effect let me uh let's do another
thought experiment here uh let's say
there were a fire at a fertility clinic
right and you could rescue a kid in the
the waiting room or a bunch of test tube
embryos
so who would you rescue the test tubes
or would you rescue the child first
well
these sort of hypothetical situations
are are really cute um
and they're i don't think they're cute i
don't they're not meant to do anything
i'm just trying to what are you saying
that uh there's an equivalency
an emotional reaction
um i get that
but
all i get you're not answering i get
that you're not answering the question
so you would save the you would save the
uh the the tubes before the uh
listen take a puff on your vape listen
to me
not rescuing someone like what i'm
hearing but i will yeah sure
um it's not the same as directly killing
them
okay
so
there's really a false equivalence there
um
so here's here's a here's a thought
experiment for you schuyler so
uh let's say there was a fire
and
you had to choose between saving your
own child which i doubt you have but
let's pretend that you do
um
and
saving a
black child that's not yours which one
would you say
um well first off you know what they say
about assumptions makes an ass out of
you and me but in this case
just you because i would save the black
child first
make sure you check your shoes and or
gloves if they've been around any dead
foliage or dry wood piles
don't even make a joke about it because
brown recluse is nothing to mess with